برنامج محاسبه
لانه نبي نصير
يعني شركه رقم واحد او الشركه التقني رقم
واحد
التاجر التجزئه والله رحت ما في احد ما
حبيت خشمه عشان يستخدم البرنامج في
البدايه ناس كثير والله بس جربوها اثنين
والله احب قرابه 7% من التعاملات السنويه
الان يمر من خلال السيستم حقنا سبعة
بالميه من التجزئه السعوديه
في المبيعات خلال الاربعه سنوات الماضيه
ست مئه سبعه اضعاف
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم ضيفنا اليوم مؤسس وحده من اكبر
الشركات اللي تقدم حلول اداره المخزون
والمبيعات لتجاره تجزئه شركه لواء اخر كم
سنه كانت تبيع في السنه الواحده مبيعات
تقريبا سبع اضعاف السنه اللي قبلها وصلت
المبيعات من خلال المنصه تسعه مليون ريال
تقريبا وقفلوا مؤخرا جوله استثماريه بقيمه
100 مليون ريال فحبيت اليوم استضيف مؤسسها
محمد القصير اسولف مع تجربته في تاسيس
الشركه وتطوير منتجاتها الى ما وصلت
لشكلها الحالي الشركه اولي بسيط برنامج
كاشير ثم قررت تدريجيا تطور منتجاتها بحيث
يصير فيه برنامج محاسبي برنامج اداره
مخزون ومجموعه من الخصائص الثانيه ثم
صاروا يبيعون الاجهزه العملائهم مع
البرنامج
فقط وبعدها صار يقدمون خدمات مدفوعات
بالشراكه مع البنوك وغيره من الاشياء اللي
بنغطيها بالحلقه خلالها التجربه مره
بتحديات كثيره جدا سواء في كيف يصممون
برنامج مناسب للمحلات بمختلف انواعها
والمشاكل المرتبطه بالاجهزه السيئه اللي
منتشره بالمحلات في السوق اللي كانوا
يشترون منها ويبيعون للعملاء والصدمه اللي
جاتهم مكتشفه والكثير من اصحاب
المحلاتهم ولا مخزون هم اساسا بشكل جيد
حلقه اليوم حلقه دسمه ومليانه تفاصيل عن
تطوير المنتجات والتسويق والمبيعات لهذا
النوع من المنتجات فاترككم معها
يلا ابو عساف الله يحييك يا اهلا وسهلا في
موضوع اسمه مثير للاهتمام يدخل فيه قبل
الحلقه كنا نسولف على هواياتنا
والله احاول احاول اني اتبنى بعض الهوايات
ويعني
نوعا ما تحس كذا في لحظه مع نفسك قلت يا
اخي
الطريقه اللي يفكر فيها اذا كان انه ممتع
الشيء اللي قاعد تسويه انت مستمتع فيه فما
اعتقد انه يكون شغل يعني فهذا هو المبدا
والله صح لكن هذا الواقع
2019 او 2018
فتشوفني اشتغل كثير
ابغى اتكلم معك وكده قلت بصراحه استغربت
تماما
يعني
لطالما فيه خلينا نقول
او حتى مكان فيه بالضبط تطور في العمل
لطالما انك مستمتع صدقني ما راح يكون شغلي
انا
ان شاء الله والله نشوف كيف أنعس
جدا
طيب انت ذكرتهم موضوع امريكا انت رحت
امريكا
يعني اجهزه ومرتبطه ما قلت لي عنه هو
قبلها في 2008 كان عندي منتدى على نيوز
على على موقع اخباري
وجاء واحد كمبيوتر
[موسيقى]
هذا مبلغ ممتاز الثانوي
يعني فوق الخمسين خمسين دولار لا ريال
طبعا كان في السعوديه
فاكتشفت ان التقنيه دي فلوس وانت
سالفه
اخباري على يعني كان في شوي فكره جديده مو
منتدى كان اخبار والناس تتعلق عليه يعني
تكتب عليه بناء على الخبر ويكتبون محتوى
بناء عليه فكان في فكره مختلفه شوي
يعني
على طول تقريبا يعني بعد سنتين
ممتازه بس اكتشفت وانا ماخذه هوايه
فالموضوع صار لا والله ترى سهل فيها فلوس
ففتح عيوني على ترى التقني بجيب فلوس زين
بعدها في 2010 او نهايه تسعه
رحت امريكا
[ضحك]
تقنيه شوي معقده
الفكره منها انك تصور جسمك ثلاثي الابعاد
وبعدين اعطيك حسابات دقيقه عن جسمك والى
اخره بحيث انه افيد الناس حقين الجمه اللي
قالتهم النادي الناس الصحيحين
وبالضبط
كانت وقتها نهايه
والله واحنا نبني المنتج طالع المنتج
الاولي لكن كان عندنا امل انه الايفون او
ثلاث كاميرات هذا بيطلع كان في سنه تقريبا
كنا نحل اللي سويناه كامل
وكاميرات ثلاثيه الابعاد وكان صراحه غالي
ست يعني اغلبك
فكنا نقول انه لا بعد ما يجي الايفون
بتصير تقنيه رخيصه ننتظر الايفون
وبدينا نشتغل لكنه كانت التقنيه فعلا
مكلفه وفي تصنيع وفي يعني تفاصيل خلنا
نقول تجربه هذيك ادبتني انه لا تبالغ في
في يعني في التقنيات
وتوقعاتك تحدي كبير اذا انت بتحاول تقدم
الجهاز
البرمجيات عكس ناس كثير
بس بس انك تسوي الجهاز
فهذه
تحدي كبير رجعت سويتها
ههه
لا بس عاد مره ثانيه بطريقه مختلفه ولو
كنت قاتل ما نسويه فبنجيها لكنه اللي صار
انها ما ضبطت السالفه قررنا انتظرنا ايفون
اعل نوع الايفون اللي فيه 2016 ما نزل ما
طلع في ثلاث كاميرات صارت صراحه شوي احباط
قلنا بنكمل الين الين الين 17 ونشوف كملنا
وكملنا شغل كنت اشتغل طبعا وكان عندي
وبرضو ما نزل الايفون ثلاث كاميرات قررنا
انه تدريب
عشان تقنيه تصير ممتازه يعني عشان التقنيه
تصير بدل ما هي الاثنين
ثلاث كاميرات تحديدا لانه عشان يصور ثري
دي اوكي هاي السالفه انه طبعا حساس مهم
ولكن الاساس الاساس بالكاميرات يعني حلو
وليش قررت ان بعد ان ما ودي صراحه اطول
كثير في القصه ابي اعرف وش اللي خلاك
تقرتني
وقتها الحراك والوضع اللي صار في السعوديه
كذا
صار في حراج صار في يعني شوي جديه يعني
الرجال السعوديه على نهايه تقريبا 17
القصه صدقني ولكن بكل بساطه يعني كانت
عمليه شوي صرت ابحث وشو ما بيسوي خلاص ابي
اشتغل
ولا بتوظفها بيركز يعني انا كنت اشتغل في
امريكا وكنت كان عندي والنقطه الثالثه
انه يكون سوق كبير
عن طريقه اللي اذا بتدخل في سوق خذ سوي
استفتاء على
نسبه الرضا عن شلون
انه لازم يعني بشكل خلينا نقول عشوائي شوي
تروح تسال الناس وش رايك البرنامج اللي
معك او ايش رايك في الخدمه الفلانيه طيب
هل ممكن نصحني اني انا اخر نفس الخدمه
اللي تستخدمها
يعني رضا منخفض فبالتالي واحده من الاشياء
اللي اشتغلنا عليها فعلا كان انه الناس مو
براضيه يعني الخدمه بس قبلها القطاع كيف
حد الانقطاع كيف انه خلاص بشتغل في القطاع
هذا
نخليها بشكل مبسط للناس تبي تشوف فيه فرصه
في سوق معين شف من اللاعبين الموجودين في
السوق نروح عند العملاء هذولي استفتهم عن
في استخدام الام بي اس كور اللي هو تقييم
من واحد الى عشره شف اللي هو قسم مستوى
الرضا يعني الخدمه تسالهم الى اي درجه
ممكن ينصحون فيها احد ثاني صح بعدين تاخذ
تقييماتهم وتشوف طبعا هذه بحسبه سريعه
هنا للتطوير حلو فنيجي الاخير يعني خلينا
نقول
لقينا فرصه مثلا
بدينا نسوي الناس مواقع نجرب او بديت اسوي
ناس مواقع اكتشفت الناس تخلي شغلها يعني
بعد فتره تترك الالكتروني فعرفت انها
مشكله الكتروني اوكي صارت المشكله شوي
اكبر انه اصلا ما يقدر يسوق بعد تجاره
الكترونيه بعدين طلعت بفكره انه خلاص
توقعت هذه الفكره اللي بتكسر الدنيا انه
نربط
بعطيك مخزون وبخليك تربط مع وقتها سوق
وادي والتفاصيل هذه وتبيع الاشياء هذه
كلها بسم الله بعدين نربط مع سوق الا صار
استحواذ السوق
وقالوا خلاص
الايميل قالوا خلاص ترى بنوقف الربط وكذا
ونروح خلاص يا جماعه الخير كان البزنس صفر
من جديد
اشترك وقتها ثلاثه قالوا خلاص سلام عليكم
تدري
ايه
سبحان الله قلتلها اوكي بكمل حالي
بديت شوي شوي جاني واحد من الشباب ذاك
الوقت جاني وقال لي طيبته
[موسيقى]
البرنامج اللي فيه اداره الموارد حق
الشركه يكون في محاسبه ونقاط بيع واداره
المخزون المخزون والتفاصيل فكان في رؤيه
حالمه يعني تجاه انها في اربع سنوات
بنكملها الاشياء
بالاخير
يعني اصلا هذا
الربط اصلا على طول يعني وعد في لحظته
سبحان الله
بعد قررني بكمل
ابدا ابدا
يعني من قضيه الكاشير ومن قضيه اساسا انه
لما تيجي تقوله تعال ويلا بعون لاين يقول
لك اساسا انا ما اعرف ايش يصير في الفرع
عندي كمل الانتفنيت عليه
على طول بالضبط انا عندي مشاكل اكبر اصلا
في هذا ليش ما تكمل
كذا جاني شعورنا يا اخي فكرتك يا شيخ ما
تحمس
مشكله
يا اخي
والله العظيم
مبهر وفعليا جاني فلاش باك يعني قصه
امريكا تخيل انه يا اخي مو لازم من قصه
الحماس عرفت لا ترى ممكن انه فعلا حل
المشكله الاكبر بالنسبه للعميل بس وقتها
السوق ما كان 2018
ما كان السوق زحمه اليوم مثلا في مليون
الف أيه السوق
ترى مو كان اغلبهم
الكمبيوتر يعني الاغلب
يبيعون لك الجهاز الجهاز
كمبيوتر عندك المحل
وفي برنامج فلاين ويجيك اللي يدربك على
النظام يقول لك فيها
خمسه بالمئه
يعني زين
سبحان الله اتخذت القرار
في قضيه خلاص بنحط ما ادري الكاشير وبيصير
بنختم قضيه الكاشير طيب رجعت
لا ما نبيع اجهزه فقط خلاص انت راعي
البقاله ولا المحل عندك جهازك حنا بس تنزل
عليه برنامجنا النقطه المهمه هنا ومن
الاشياء اللي حمستنها اصلا وانا كنت ناقشه
انه فعليا فيه عدم رضا على الوضع اللي كان
موجود هناك البرامج يضيع مثلا خلاص يضيع
تفاصيل كثيره ولما نقول له يا ابن الحلال
يعني الامور طيبه يعني
بالضبط فانه كان وضحت الفرصه مره فتنازلت
المسيطر على السوق مدري اليوم اليمن سوف
تظلمة أي لا طبعا لكنه ما زالت موجوده في
السوق بس انها استهدفتها جديده مختلفه
يعني
تسلم
الكلام وين الكلام انه
لا فعليا الناس محتاجه هذا البرنامج اكثر
بكثير من الربط والفلسفه هذي واضح
فمشينا فيه كان فكره انه
الين يصير عندي منتج اولي يوم خلاص حطينا
فكره انك تسوي وانت ما عندك منتجة كارثيه
الى درجه
لانه لابد تثبت مدى قدرتك على انشاء شركه
باقل الموارد حلو وش تتوقع هذه ينعكس
يعني متوسط القدره على انشاء شركه بدون
موارد عشان انا اثق واعطيك فلوسي بالبدايه
فالمستثمر بالاساس يعطيك بالغالب يعطيك
فلوس عشان في شويه نار ويزود على النار
شوي نعطي نار كبيره مو بالنهايه انك تتعلم
على فلوسها بالغالب ما هي مو بهذا او على
الاقل يعني الوضع في وقت الدول الناضجه
كذا المفروض انك ما انك تنشئ منتج من
السفر ارجع اعطيك فلوس
يعني حتى في 2018 كان اكيد الفلوس في كل
مكان وكان سهل بالنسبه لي صراحه ترى موضوع
الفلوس ما كان صعب بس كانت تجربه انه كان
مبدا
2018 الى 2020
حنا اطلقنا في جانوري 2019 ما طولنا لاني
اربع شهور واطلقنا المنتج ترى في 2018
اربعه تقريبا ثلاثه اربعه بدينا بشكل فعلي
اول اول سطر برمج كتبناه كيف شهر اربعه
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
انطلق بادخارك الادخار يخلصك من الديون
يمنحك الحريه الماليه لبدء مشروعك بنفسك
حمل تطبيق سيركليز
حلو كم عميل حاول فكره معه قبل ما تكلموا
مستثمرين
على البرنامج زين بس انه بس واضح انه
البرامج بينباع يعني
وضحت انه البرنامج راح ينباع في في
البدايه انت الحين عشان الشخص اللي يبغى
يسوي نموذج اولي المنتج في محل من اول ناس
كلمتهم والله راحت ما في احد ما حبيت خشمه
عشان يستخدم البرنامج
والله احب خشوم فزعه
هذا التفسير الوحيد اول شيء بدفعهم فلوس
لا تجي ثم قلت خلاص خلاص بجان ثم فتره مش
دعوه وبعدين كملنا شغل بس خلاص احنا
البرنامج بدا شوي قابل يصير قابل
للاستخدام
صرت ادور واحد فاينس عشان اسوي
الاستثمار
ومعارف اسوي
مقابلاتك واقابل شريك يا عبد القضي عن
طريق توصيه
مقابله بعد وصل المخابره
يعني
ما غير يتكلم عن برمجيات طبعا عبد الله هو
الان ماسك يعني وفعلا الان ماسك القسم
التقني بالشركه بس هو متعدل مواهب
تشغيل واللي تبيه
صارت المقابله بدل ما هي مقابله صارت اني
اقول
مثلا على اشياء مثلا
الله اشياء بسيطه
خلاص
يعني
نبيه فقلت له
فصارت السالفه شريكي
فعلا مع الوقت وده خلاص وافق ودخلوا
البدايه انه بيختبرنا شوي ورانا ترى خلاص
جاهزين طبعا
الحين مساله على ما قال شركه ملياريه
فهوافق
وقال استنى بالله وبدا معنا قعد شهر طيب
وش التوجه ليش الحين
يتغير ما بين نموذج الاول وهو العميل فعلا
يتبنى
البرنامج شوي يعني صار يشتغل ما في خطاب
الارقام صار في اساسيات بالمخزون وصار في
اساسيات يعني بالكاشير صفحه المبيعات كذا
صار فيه اساسيات يعني فانتم تعلمتم انقص
هذه بالضبط خلينا نقابل اصغر نسخ نسخه
قابل الاستخدام لو تشوفها تقول ايش اللعبه
بس الحمد لله مشيت فاول ما قفلنا هذا
ونروح للمستثمرين ونقول ترى هذه البدايه
الان
حنا خلال اربع سنوات نوصل على مقام
وبعد تقريبا خمس سنوات بقول لك انه 30%
تحققت الحمد لله
فهذه كانت في البدايه بشكل خطط عموما
الطويله دي
تحقق في نفس الطريق مكتوبه بس انا اودي
الحين نبدا نفصل شوي
نسولف فيها للناس اللي مهتمين في القطاع
هذا لو واحد بيسوي بزنس لو واحد بيتعلم
كل الموضوع على حدا بس قبل ما ندخل
بالتفصيل هذا ودي تشرح لي اليوم
بالضبط لو تتذكر قلنا بالبدايه انه
الاولي صار برنامج كاشير
واداره مخزون مخصصه التجزئه
اختلفت شويه الان اختلف المنتج زي ما قلنا
الرؤيه وضع الرؤيه برامج محاسبي فاليوم وش
نسوي اليوم
ايه
وعندنا اللي هو الميزه اللي احنا مختلفين
فيها عن البرامج الثانيه اننا نربط مع
المتاجر الالكترونيه بطريقه مره ممتازه
ففرعك يصير اونلاين نفس الفكره الاولى
اللي احنا بدينا فيها وماتت
اليوم شوف شوف نفسك من زاويه محاسبيه اكثر
من زاويه اداره محل او من اداره مبيعات لا
هو جزء من اداره المحل اذا كبرت لازم يصير
عندي قناه محاسبي انا فهمت انه انتظر نفسك
برنامج محاسبه اكثر منك الحين رابط فيها
المخزون مبيعات الفرع وكل شيء بالضبط انت
تقدم نفسك كبرنامج محاسبي اكثر من
البرنامج محاسبي للتجزئه لازم يصير فيه
الكاشير ولازم يصير فيه المخزون كل النقاط
اللي قاعد
يجالس اخدمه
هذه هي الرؤيه هذه هي التوجه
بالشو اسمه
برنامج محاسبه لانه نبي نصير
يعني شركه رقم واحد او الشركه التقني رقم
واحد
التاجر التجزئه
ومنها بعد تربطونه من كل مكانه بالضبط
فانا اكبر ما يا سلام عليك فجلسين نكبر مع
العميل العميل والله الان يبي برنامج
محاسب جالس اعطيه برنامج محاسبه وبكمل معه
وبكمل بالعميل يعني الحين الناس
مثلا والله بقول اني ابى اصير اخدم حقينا
ما اعرف مثلا حقينا الاستشارات الهندسيه
في قضيه حسابه حساب عدد الساعات
تدخل تقوم البدايه تبدا كاشير بعدين تكتشف
انه مثلا هم يقول لك تربط مع البرنامج
اللي عندي حق كذا تقول طيب ليش ما ابدا
اقدم الخدمه هذه وهكذا ليه ما تتعمق اكثر
في الخدمات اللي تقدمها هو في رؤيه هو في
رؤيه وتصير تستبدل الخدمات اللي
يستخدمونها اليوم يصير يتخلص من برنامج
المحاسب يصير يتخلص من برنامج المخزون
يصير تتخلص
جزء جزء عندك موضوع او الاجهزه انتم اليوم
تبيعون الجهاز
ومع البرمجيات طبعا
وش اللي خلاك تقول انا ببدا باجهزه
خلاص انت عندك تابلت ولا عندك جهاز ويندوز
انا بصير موجود عليه
حنا صرنا نسحب من السوق خسرنا نغير موردين
من وقت للثاني يجي عميل يزعل يقول خذ
البرنامج هذا خلاص ما عاد ابيه ليش اكتب
انه المشكله بالهاردوين اللي معاه الجهاز
مو قاعد يشغل
ولاننا احنا ويب نشتغل عن طريق متصفح فثقل
على الرام
بطيء معه فيتوقع انه البرنامج هو اللي
بطيء
اليوم مش اكبر مشكله يشتكون منها ملاك
يقول والله بطيء البرنامج مع انه على
اجهزتنا لا بالعكس مره ممتازه انه يكون
اصلا يستخدم جهاز مورد ثاني
منخفضه الجهاز عشان يطلع له تكلفه اقل ما
الى انه التاج الحسبه هذه طيب طيب انا رحت
وشريت من السوق يجي يقول مثلا والله هذا
اربع رام وهذا المواصفات ممتازه وبناء على
الفحص اللي انا اسويه يقول لك انه شغلك
ممتاز بعدين لا اذا جيت اكتب انه صح
المواصفات صحيح على كلمه اجزاء الهاردوير
او اجزاء الجهاز غلط تلقاه مشاري مستعمل
من المصنع الصين شاري مثلا الرام من اجهزه
اتلفت ولا تلاقيها الشاشه ولا
المعالج يسمونه اللي هو يعني شارينهم
بالسوق الثاني بالضبط مستخدم فاوكي ممتازه
بس رديئه
فبالتالي وصلنا مرحله انه انت حبيبي لا
لابد عشان العميل يكون راضي عنك بشكل تام
لابد انك تمسك الساكن من اوله فكان في ضغط
علينا ندخل السوق هذا
بحكم التجربه حقت الهاردوير فعليا تحققت
اكره
يعني حاربنا الى اخر لحظه انه يا جماعه
الخير يا جماعه الخير
يلا معه الهاردوير
المبيعات اتذكر ارتفعت 33% او زي كذا لا
العميل يبي انه خلاص ابي اشتري برنامج
افضل والله انه الظاهر الاثنين بس
فبدايه الاجهزه من اجهزه البي سي ولا
الاندرويد
والكلام وين صار الامين اصلا يقول لي
شو اسمه اذا اذا انت تبي اذا تبي نفعل
بسرعه البرنامج
بعد ما خلاص تعبنا الصراحه كله تدريب
بعد نقاش طويل وكذا قلنا خلاص بنروح للصين
وطبعا حنا اخذنا عادي يعني لا بدينا بشيء
لا بد انه نحرص انه يكون بعد جوده ممكنه
والله ونجيب لنا من الشباب مدير المنتج
عنده تجربه يعني اجنبي ممتاز مره بالحاره
وايضا الناس من الفريق عندنا اطلعوا الصين
الله هو اساسا شركه ومسكني
ليش خلاص حنا ترى اذا دخلنا بشيء لازم انه
يكون يعني لازم نقدم تجربه مثاليه للعميل
بالاخير حلو الكلام ده جميل بس ليش تسوي
شركه بالصين لانه ابي ابي يعني اصنع
بالصين واجيب للسعوديه
يعني نوع من انواع الحوكمه يعني اله علاقه
بالحوكمه وكذا لانه احنا اخذنا خط انتاج
عرفت يعني احنا ما شرينا من يعني ما
اشترينا من واحد قصدي يعني احنا شرينا خط
انتاج كامل
لانه يعني كاني انا ملك خط الانتاج نفسه
اشتغلنا بقضيه
قصدي
تكون ككاشير سواء او جهاز كمبيوتر او
اجهزه تابلت ولا صارت قصه مؤلمه خلاني مره
ناخذ دفعني بالسوق وشرينا من واحد من
الموردين كنا نتعامل مع دراسه تقريبا
ثمانيه شهور نحن نتعامل معه كان في شكاوي
بسيطه على ارض حقه الاجهزه بس انها كانت
منطقيه حق الكشري
قلنا خلاص يلا بنطلبها 500 جهاز اللي صار
قال تم جاب نصين صارت الاجهزه اللي جاب
لنا غير اللي بالعاده نشتري منه اوكي
تخيل انه تقريبا يعني
رجعناه قال العميد قاعد يشتكي ودفعنا احنا
من جيبنا للعميل وغيرنانه الجهاز ثاني
فكانت اجربه يعني مريره يعني كانت خساره
يعني مو بسيطه الصراحه
فهذا ولد غضب داخلي يعني
نبي ندخل وبنغير السوق هذا نبي نطلع كل
الكاشيرات زي ناس ثانيين في السوق لا
انجحوا بعض الاجهزه
زينة
ولكنه ترى يعني ايضا قضيه الجوده وقضيه
السعر كانت بالنسبه لي لانه لازم اخلي
عميلي ما يخسر لانه الهاردوير مو باللي
اكسب منه
في المطاعم وحلات غالبا هو يستقبل طلبات
التوصيل وشركه صينيه تتعامل عاده مع وكيل
محل اللي هو اس تي سي حاليا بحيث يورد
الاجهزه هذه وتورد للشركات فهو اشياء
بسيطه فهمت
الغضب هذا فعلا جاب نتيجه بالاخير
في رداء يعني موهوب افضل خيار العميمي
يعني قضيه انك تقدم منتج العميلك انت تقدم
تجربه متكامله الاركان
والجوده
وبنفس الوقت انه ترى العميل متطلب
طبعا يحق له
وبجعل الموضوع العميل ولكنه فلازم انه
العميل ما يقول ليش باي شيء زين فبدينا
والله دخلنا فيها وكانت اسرع تجربه رهيبه
على مواصفاتك اي مواصفاتي وعلى تجربتي
وصار عندي حتى فريق يعني بالصين اللي اللي
ناظر خط الانتاج من يوم ما يشترون القطع
الين يوصل السعوديه في عده شركات تختبر كل
مرحله نتاكد انه هذا هنا بيتادبنا بصراحه
تجربه الجهاز هذه صنعت منه يعني اخذناها
يعني تعاملنا مع الموضوع بقسوه والتوجه
حقنا انه بنزل
بالضبط احنا الان بعدين الكمبيوتر بنشوف
مع الوقت لكن يعني كل
جهازكم
انها سعره جدا منخفض حنا تقريبا
ممتاز والجوده باعلى مواصفات ممكن تلقاها
على مواصفات جدا عاليه حلو فبالتالي السوق
السعر العادي للجهاز هذا يمكن 2,800 بس
ليش انا كذا لاني انا انا ما اهتم
بالهاردوير انا بس ابي عميلي انه يقول هذا
رهيب مره فاضطريت اني ادخل السوق هذا فانت
شفت البرنامج
بعدها تجربه القاسيه ذي لا وبنجي للسوق
وبنعطي للناس حتى انه ودنا تعرف تجربه
قالوا احنا بندخل بس عشان نقول المقاولين
ترى شغلكم
اعتقد انه حلم جاني نفس الغضب يعني انه
لابد انزلها ترى غلط يعني معيار جيد
في الشغل اللي تسوونه خاصه النظام النقاط
البيع اذا راح اعطيك جهاز مناسب بعدين
تروح تجرب مورد مورد فهذه دخلك في دوامه
لا منتهي يعني
بس انه فيها رد يعني كانت معاناه الصراحه
فقلنا بالخط الانتاج حلو
للعميل فهذا على مستوى نتكلم عن السوفت
وير او البرمجيات وش الخدمات اللي تقدم
برنامج محاسبه اللي اعطناه قبل كم شهر
وقبله كان اداره المخزون للفرع واداره
المخزون مع القنوات الالكترونيه كله
مربوطه بمكان واحد والكاشير اللي نقطه
البيع الصفحه هذه
حلوة أنا من النقاط هذول عندك اول شيء
اداره المخزون كان فيها مشاكل كبيره صح في
طريقه اضافه
مخزونها في اداره المخزون بين انواع
المحلات طبعا في ناس
فيعني عندي ارقام رسميه على الاستخدام انا
حسب الطلائكم في السوق مين اللي اصلا
يتابعون المخزون
7% من التعاملات السنويه بالريتين الان
يمر من خلال السيستم حقنا 7% من كل
تعاملات السعوديه
النظام مقارنه ثنائيه
تقريبا 210 ملي
فبالتالي يعني عندي مسحه مره ممتازه حتى
وش المضحك
وناظر ارقام الحكوميه في ريفليكس مره واضح
يعني في انعكاس
عندك عينه جيده تقدر تقول صح نسب منها كم
نسبه العملاء
والله انه شيء محزن الصراحه ولا تقريبا
30% بس
الرازق على قناه مبسمه
هذا المبدا المشكله تقنيا وما يبغون
يستخدمون طريقه اداره المخزون التقنيه لا
تصور كلهم عندهم كلهم عندهم في طريقه
معينه يعني لاداره المخزون مو قاعدين
الاشكاليه انه
بعد يعني الان طبعا قاعدين ندرس الحاله
هذه حاله اذا حليناها يكون يعني
قيمه روادك بتصير قيمته ما ادري بس يعني
احس يعني بنحل مشكله كبير مره زين فسؤالك
عميق صراحه لانه فعلا هذه
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه تكتب نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه
وممتعه خليك على اطلاع بالتخصص اللي يهمك
والمواضيع اللي تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف
اهتمامات جديده تعرف على نشراتنا عن
الحياه اليوميه والافلام والكتب حتى
كواليس اشتركت اللي يناسبك منها وتوصلك
على بريدك مباشره نترك لك رابط الاشتراك
في الوصف
[موسيقى]
يعني قديش نافش انت يعني ممتاز
قديش انها كفاءتها عاليه ترى يمكن الوضع
وطبعا هو طبيعي يعني
ان شاء الله الفراج لكن بالاخير
بس طبعا
بس الحل بالناس الواعين زين وش يقول يقول
لا بالنسبه لي مهم وخلاص وبجيب او اني انا
بدخل بنفسي ثم مع الوقت يتكاسل تقوم متحمس
بالبدايه يدخل المنتجات وشغل مرتب متكاسل
مع الوقت او ياجل
خلاص يمشي
الحل التقني متطابق مع طريقه عمل المحل
والتوقعات اللي عنده
بطريقه مختلفه عن كيف اجرد انا ولا كيف
احط مخزون ولا كيف اطلع المخزون
طريقتين احنا نشوف وش البرامج العالميه
وشيء ثاني ننزل السوق ونخلي العمله قبل ما
ننزل خاصيه هم يجربونها ويقول لا هذا
بيختمن فانا اتكلم عن الناس اللي اريدهم
قرر انه يستخدموا اداره المخزون واموره
طيبه هذا انا ابدا ما عندي مشكله معه زين
انا مشكلتي الكبيره مع اللي اصلا ما عنده
ما عنده نيه يستخدم اداره المخزن اصلا
متعب عليه
مشكله كبير
وكذا ما عندهم ما عندهم مشكله
طيب السؤال اللي نتوقع انه بيغير سوق
التجزئه وشلون اني انا اخليه اناس اول شيء
تعرف او تجاري يعرفون باهميه اذا انت تاجر
كيف تدير المخزون بشكل مره ممتاز وتقاريرك
تصير ممتازه وتتابع بشكل نظيف بطريقه سهله
وغير مكلفه بالنسبه للتاجر
ولا هذا هو سؤال اتوقع انه يعني
في محاولات عندنا محاوله الحين مشروع
قاعدين نجرب
قلنا
الذكاء الذكاء الاصطناعي والله قاعدين
نفكر انه الان موضوع فتره الكترونيه فصار
كل شيء الان يجي يجي مكتوب يجي على قولتهم
مطبوع
المورد فودنا بدانا نشرب التقنيه انه يصور
شو اسمه
الفاتوره وتدخل مباشره عنده بالجرد بلش
اسمه
المحل اذا استلم بضاعه يصور الفاتوره
حقتها على طول المخز ون
والله يعني اكيد نبي بس نعتقد حلينا
المشكله هذه نعتقد ممكن نرفعه 65%
بشكل لا بس انه
صور كثيره عشان ندرب العالم على قولتهم
لكنه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله انه يعني
التقنيه هذه بنشتغل عليه لين ان شاء الله
تنضجه اعتقد انه هو الحل ما ادري اذا في
حل ثاني ذكي بس
هو الحل اللي بيرفع الجوده
التقنيه
للمستخدم وتقول له تعال لو تستخدمها ترى
خلني اقدر يعني استخدمها بسلاسه وباستمرون
عمليات اليوميه
هذه حطها بالطريقه دي تعال لو تدخل
البيانات كذا بتزبط معك وتسحب عليها بس
انت الحين تطلع لهم
فهذه ما تنعرف اذا قاعد يسحب على يعني هذا
اللي يتعبنا احنا بالموضوع ليش مثلا مره
حريص يستخدم كل شيء بالنظام ليش انا حريصه
يستخدم المخزون اول شيء عشان يستفيدون
البرنامج عشان يحس ان البرنامج ينت وشيء
ثاني عشان
يستفيد يعني من التقارير ويصير فعلا انه
لا انا ترى ما اخذته عشان مثلا اطول
فاتوره لا انا ماخذه عشان اعرف يعني ايش
اللي يتحرك وش اللي واقف انا خسران انا
ضبحانتك الوضع
التفاصيل هذه مره طيب وش اجيب
شغل عشوائي يلا امشوا كذا
والصراحه اننا نحاول نجلس في المحلات كثير
الناس تصور ما تصورون عدد المحلات اللي في
البلد خاصه اللي عندهم محل واحد اللي ما
يحسب شيء اللي يجيك ما يدري كم قاعد يصرف
ما يدري يعني كذا اللي ماشي بالبركه والله
يضيع الصدر ويطيح يمكن الحين في ديون
القروض اللي ماشي على عمامها فهذولي اللي
حتى اقوله للزملاء يعني مرت علي اكثر من
عميل
وحتى من دائره القريبه يقول لي لولا لها
برنامجكم ايام اول المحل الثاني ما سكرته
والثاني ما سكرته ولا خسرته بعد ما يفهم
القيمه برنامج
رهيب بالنهايه اذا هو مو مقتنع بالموضوع
الوضع سهلات يعني ما راح يستخدم عشان كده
نشتغل
بالمحتوى نحاول
نختم الجانب الخدمات اللي تقدمونه محاسبه
اداره مخزون طبعا في السيستم حق الكاشير
تصور نفس الاختبارات عشان تاكدون انه ماشي
مع المحل بس
الموضوع المدفوعات دخلت فيها ولا
دخلنا موضوع المدفوعات
طبعا دخلنا بالمدفوعات لانه يعني كتجربه
الى الان احنا بمرحله التجربه للامانه
وجالسين نحاول نتعلم بالسوق هذا
في اداء ممتاز بس ما نتوقع انه المدفوعات
شيء بيكون مربعه البعيد بالذات مثلا مع
الانظمه تعرف انه مهما قدمت خدمه رهيبه
وجميله بالمدفوعات والاخير ما تقدر تدفع
قد تساعدك في انك تحكم مثلا الاستخدام
الجهاز بشكل افضل بحيث انه يستخدم الجهاز
وبعدين يروح مجرد ما يدخل الفاتوره تروح
على طول على الجهاز المدفوعات يعني يكون
متحفز اكثر ان لازم يدخل المبلغ بشكل دقيق
ما يسلك بالفواتير صح على اساس انه يجمع
فعلا هي بالنهايه طبعا انا كنت ضده زين
كنت ضد المدفعات تماما قاعد اشوف انه
السوق تقريبا كله اربع مليار ارباح
المدفوعات شركات المنفوعات بس بترفع دقه
البيانات يعني هو بموضوع بشكل
اربع مليار وفي مدري تشتغل فيه وكل
الشركات ممتازه ورائده
وفعلا السوق متشبع جدا من قضيه المدفوعه
زين ولو ابتكر وابدع فيه وبسوي اشياء
جميله جدا اساسا الدعوه كلها ثمانيه من
الالف وعلى العمالقه على فبالتالي ما هو
مجدي من ناحيه ماديه انك تدخل في
المدفوعات الحين صارت خلاص
استثمار فيه انك تبتكر بالعمليه هذه ويكون
جميل وكذا ليش لانه محدود
انظمه حكوميه حاده قضيه
واضح طيب
خلاني اروح
انه لا والله ما مدفوعات المنتجات عندنا
واحد من الشباب اصر انه كان عنده كيس قوي
زي ما تفضلت قصه عطاني قصه
وقال لا انه نبي نقدم تجربه مكتمله للعميل
انه العميل يجي ياخذ من الجهاز ويجي ياخذ
من المدفوعات اوكي بعيدا عن الربحيه لكنه
بيخوتها خلنا نقول مكتمله زي ما تفضلت
مشهور زين وفعلا هذا اللي هذا اللي صار
يوم بدا بدينا على مضى خلاص يعني احنا
بالنهايه نوع من الارقام وكان مجهز لي
انا ما قال يعني زين فخلاص حنا نؤمن
بالارقام
قلنا بسم الله استنى بالله خلاص يلا بدينا
بدينا
وغير مفهومي
مختلفه شوي اللي هم يسمونه
اللي هي رخصه اني انا اقدم دفعات للعميل
خدمات المدفوعات للتجار ايه هذه وش فرقها
عن انك تكون شركه مصرحه عند البنك المركزي
هذه فكره عبقريه صراحه صارت من
من سامه ومن المدفات السعوديه
انه شلون بدال ما العالم تطلع رخصه تطلع
رخص وتقدمه الى اخره يصير في واحد يبيع
البنيه التحتيه حقت المدفوعات وتصير في
نسخه كذا بسيطه ان ان الشركات هذه تقدم
خدمه المنفوعات بدون ما تروح مع الرخصه حق
التامه لانه اغلب اللي قد مو رخصه ما
يستمرون او يعني
وسنوات
تاخذ سنوات زين
بالضبط بس نسبه كبيره من الناس يمكن ما
يقدرون
ومن ناحيه متطلبات
بس فانت
فهذه الفكره منها انه لا خلاص انا ممكن
اني اخذ بنيه تحتيه من واحد من الشركات
زين
والشركه هذه خلاص انا اعتمد عليها وانطلق
على طول في المدفوعات خلال اسبوعين
لتقديم خدمه بتجربه كلها وكذا بس انا عصير
على قررتهم الفوق اللي فوق اللي اقابل
العميل وانا اللي ابيع المنتج حقي والى
اخره فانت تصير هذه تصير في الواجهه تقدم
خدمه المدفوعات للشركه وباسمي زين ولكن
انا ما اجمع فلوس التجميع يصير عن طريق
البنوك
انت الحين تتعامل المصرح نتعامل مع البنوك
لتقديم خدمه المدفعات حلو الفلوس تروح
للبنك
انا اقدم من هذه مدفوعات لواء اللي هي جوا
برنامج جوا وزين وانا ادير العمليه كلها
زين
ولكن يعني بالنسبه للعميل هو يتعامل
مدفوعات زين
لكن بالواقع انا اخذت البنيه التحتيه
الموجوده القويه اللي طبعا في السعوديه من
افضل دول في قضيه المدفعه فبالتالي
اخذوني تحتيه الموجوده وعلى طول اقدم
الخدمه بشكل تقريبا اسبوعين ثلاث اسابيع
اتذكر وطلعنا فيها في تحديات مال البنوك
لكنه خدمه طلع فيها بسرعه حلو طيب
اني اقدم تجربه مكتمله بالنسبه العميلي بس
انتوا ايش تحتاج تطلع التصريح هذا
متطلبات على السيكيوريتي في قضيه الواجهه
حقت المدفعات حقتنا يعني ما اتذكر بالضبط
بسيطه لكنها سهله وبسيطه يعني
دخلنا على موضوع نموذج العمل ابي اعرف اول
شيء كان كيف اريد تسعير عندكم وش مصادر
الدخل اليوم
من المدفوعات طبعا
الشيء الاساسي بالنسبه لنا
الاشتراكات فانت عندك قيمه الجهاز اللي
تبيعه بسعر التكلفه وتبيع الاشتراكات
طبعا ناخذ الكوست زين تكلفه تكلفه فعلا
اخذ التكلفه وبعدين
نشوف وش ممكن العميل يقدر يدفع وش القيمه
الحين جالسين نقدم العميل هل فعلا ان انا
جالس
اوفر للعميل فلوس وازيد من ربحيه العميل
ولا لا بس شلون قص التكلفه ولا قصدك
بعدين تشوف العميل كم يدفع بالسوق يعني
بشكل
موظفين رواتب المبيعات الدعم الفني
المنتج نفسه
اوكي
وناظر يعني خلال كم انا بربح لو
يعني لو مثلا بعته مثلا فانت سوي لك نموذج
اجمالي اللي تشوف على عدد سنوات معينه هذا
التكلفه بالضبط بتكون تطلع لك التكلفه كم
شهريه ولا السنويه
لو تبي بالساعه خلاص اذا طلعتها خلينا
نقول السنويه طيب بدون ما تعمق
فانت هذي نقطه عندك في نقطه ثانيه
بالضبط بس نكملوا ترى اقل من التكلفه
المشتركات تموت هنا اصلا زين او العكس او
انك مثلا سعر اقل من يحتاج العميل اسف اقل
من يقدر يدفع العميل
حلو فتخسر فتخسر لكن
هو تحدي صراحه كبير مره اللي احنا سويناه
انه يعني اعترضنا الاسوا وان العلبه مثلا
وبدينا من سعر مره قليل حلو اقل من تكلفه
ولا
بالبدايه كان اقل من تاكلها حلو فانت عندك
تدخل من الاشتراكات عندك من الاجهزه بسعر
التكلفه تقول
والمدفوعات ايضا عندك يعني تاخذ منها نسبه
بسيطه جدا
تقريبا هذه
القطاعات اللي تستهدفونها
الاساسيه عندنا 14 قطاع اساسي بس من ابرز
القطاعات هذي بقالات ملابس
كماليات
المحلات الورود والعسل
يعني اللي عندها مخزون تقريبا تقريبا اي
قطاع في التجزئه عنده مخزون نختمه بشكل
مره مره ممتاز مثالي
البقالات راح تتفاجا انه افضل افضل امين
نخدم البقالاتي
انت عندك بقاله عندك سوبر ماركت عندك يعني
في مجموعهم كلهم تقصد افضل عميل عندنا
اللي عنده تقريبا اللي بين ثلاث الى ثمان
فتحات
يعني انا
التستر
ما اسوا يعني ما تخيلوا قديش احنا اعداء
اللي يبغى البرنامج يبحث عن قيمه
يبي كل شيء هو اللي حسبه نفسه ولا ولا
يبحث عن برنامج عشان يكبر نشاط حقه لا هو
طموحه البقاله اللي هو ماخذه من الشخص
اللي يدفع له ولا عنده طموح انه يكبر وكذا
وبالتالي
اغلب عملائكم اللي عندهم فرعين ثلاثه او
اكثر لانه يبدا يدخل في حوسه بس يكون كبير
بس يبدا من فرع اثنين ثلاثه بس يكون كبار
ما تكون صغيره فهذا العميل اللي عاده حتى
لو عنده يوصل نقطه اللي احتاج يدير
المخزون
البرامج
المايكرو لا ما لواء ما يخدمهم قنوات
التسويق عندكم مش نستخدم كل شيء
ابتداء من الدجيتال
تبي الله يطول بعمرك
تيك توك
اي شيء يقول في ناس بس حسب تجربتكم مش
اكثر شيء يناسب او وين اكثر تواجد لعميل
اللي هو الشركات
راح تتفاجا انه سناب شات تصدق أقولها سناب
شات وطبعا جوجل اد اعلانات جوجل حقت البحث
هذه هذه افضل قناتين عندنا يلا نروح ندور
نظام
بالضبط ولا مثلا نظام اداره مخزون ولا
نظام كاشير والنظام محاسبي فهذا افضل قناه
عندنا الثانيه او يجي معه قريب منه مره
سناب شات
[موسيقى]
زين واستمرينا بالاستثمار فيه كاني
متوقعين انه يوما ما بيضبط معنا المحتوى
اليوم جالسين يبيع مبالغ بره ممتازه من
خلال المحتوى العمله اللي يدخلون على
حقتنا على المدونات
يعني
جاب لكم
كانت اكبر كانت التوقعات مره منخفضه
شفت انه في ناس كثير معروفه لواء المخلفات
اللي يدخل على البودكاست اليوم بيشوف
المشاهدات طبعا مقارنه ببرامج ثانيه
بشوفها قليله لكن في عشرات
حقكم
اطلاقا مبيعات كان ودنا انه الناس تفهم
مثلا اهميه او تجار يفهمونها المخزون يفهم
الاشياء البسيطه التكتيكات اللي بالتسويق
بالضبط على قولات نخلق زي المجتمع التجاره
تجزئه اللي عندهم فروع جربتو
يضبط
الشركات والله يعني شباب
ايش قاعد تسويق الاستماريه
انا
زين كمل الان اليوم
حنا بدينا نعلم مع المشاهير
طريقه التفكير هذه كم اليوم
القوه العامله بالسعوديه كم عدد السعوديين
اللي يشتغلون اليوم بقطاع الحكومه الخاص
اربع مليون زين عدد السجلات التجاريه
مليون و400
وفي ناس مكتوبه اساميهم بعد اوكي بس نتوقع
انه لا يقل عن مليونين لانه شريك في
القطاع او انه يملك بشكل مباشر بالقطاع
فتخيل انه نصف القوه العامله
فئه بالنسبه لنا محتمله او عميل محتمل
كبير جدا يمكن تنظر لها من زاويه كفاءه
التسويق انك انت قاعد كانك ترمي شبك كذا
على مجموعه كبيره تقول يا رب انه في احد
اسمك اسمك
[ضحك]
لكن لكنه يعني يعني ودنا لو اقول لك
اي مكان في مليان سمك
احنا الحين قلنا خلاص جربتوا كل قنوات
التسويق ودك قبل المشاهير انه هذا ترى
اكثر موضوع ترى انسى انا يعني
اذا كان يجيب لي هذه قاعده بساس بساس اللي
هو التقديم البرمجيات الخدمه بالضبط هذه
قاعده عامه اذا كان عائد الاعلان واحد
فاكثر امورك طيبه حنا عائد المشاهير عندنا
مثلا كان تقريبا واحد فاصله سته تقريبا وش
قصتك واحد ولا واحد
الاستثماري من غطى قيمته وجاب لي تقريبا
خمسين بالمئه زياده على قيمه ادفع المشهور
الى المشاهير للمشاهير كما فعل المشاهير
او لاحد المشاهير
لاحد المشاهير دفعت مثلا عشر الاف كم جتني
المبيعات منها العشر
بالضبط لا اضعاف بس يبيع لك كم ليبيعلك
اربعه دبلت بحس انه منطقي
البزنس حقنا زين طريقه
اذا جاب لك اكثر من واحد امورك طيبه
ليش لانه العميل انا عندي يقعد خمسين الى
ست سنوات متوسط بقاء العميل عندي اللي
يسمونه حياه العميل عندي خمس سنوات الى ست
سنوات
بالضبط
فبالتالي هي الحسبه اذا كانوا من اول مره
جاب لي اكثر من واحد معناته انه اصلا جاب
لي سته
لانه حجم متوسط رياضيا سته
اوكي فانت اذا صرفت مبلغ معين على احد
المشاهير
[موسيقى]
اللي يتناظر يعني تاخذ الاعتبار
عادل العملاء يشتركون الجدد زين
وتناظر عدد الانسحابات
فتعرف خلال سنه اللي ما يجددون ترى هذا
يعني معناته انه خدع الخمس سنوات مثلا او
ست سنوات وترى يعني خلال كم كل العمله
بيطلعون يعني كل ما يعني
اكثر يصير عندكم متوسط للعدد الانسحابات
لا كل ما قل عدد الانسحابات عندي معناته
انه مده بقاء العميل عندي اعلى
بس ما راح تكون بدقه انه الرقم
الثاني تكشفنا 18 تقول اوكي الحين اقدر
اكون اكثر ثقه السنه الثالثه
متفائل جدا
عبد الله
فانت يعني تقول تبرر الاستثمار بهالطريقه
انه حسبت المتوسط
نفس الطريقه وكذا يعني العميل الان وش
يواجه اول شيء
جاء العميل سجل بالصفحه يدخل في الموقع او
دق لكنه مثلا سجل الموقع على طول ينزل
عندي بطريقه مرتبته ينزل عندي
طلب جديد مهتم
زين تجي مكالمه من عندنا ابليس اللي هم ما
قبل المبيعات يتاكدون انه هذا العميل
حقيقي عنده نشاط تجاري واربع اسئله اساسيه
اليوم تقريبا المكالمه اخر دقيقه الى
دقيقه ونص يجيكم عملاء غير حقيقيين كثير
وظائف اقصاد
طبيعي فهي البدايه عدد كبير من العملاء
المحتملين اللي اغلبهم يطلعوا العملاء
اصلا
الرقم هذا وصلنا مرحله انه المتوسط
العالمي تقريبا 64% يكونوا عملاء حقيقيه
يعني اللي يسمونهم
نشاطك تجاري اسال واسئله يعني اذا ما
جاوبة خلاص ما هو
الدين للمبيعات الان اكتب المعلومات هذه
عنه المبدئيه واجهز المبيعات عشان يدخل
معه بالمكالمه حلو فيبدا عاد موظف
المبيعات يساله اكثر وش النقاط العلم عندك
طيب ليش تبغى برنامج طيب وش ممكن يحل
بالنسبه لك وكل التفاصيل هذه
اطبخ البرنامج على حسب احتياج العميل
فهو البرنامج
لازم تحط له كل الاغراض عند النشاط عندنا
مثلا حسابات الكل نشاط
اللي مجهز فيها مجهز فيها مثلا انت مثلا
عندك بقاله عندي حساب في خمسين الف منتج
جاهز جاهز حق البقاله وصور البقاله وكل
شيء متكامل صور المنتجات قصدي
الملابس
لا اوريه محلات ملابس زيه بس لازم يصير
نفس مثلا منتجاته اوكي بس أقول هذا محل
ملابس كذا يشتغل
في اشياء مشتركه تكون بينهم
ايش رايك يعني
بعطيك رقم اعتباطي
خمسه ايام
ايه الكل عميل بعد خمسه ايام
اول ما يوقع طبعا كل العمليات مره ثانيه
كل العمليات مؤتمته يعني انه يروح من قسم
القسم يطلع من يروح لهذا مؤتمت ثم نقفل
العميل بعد ما وصل مبيعات قفل يوديهن وقفل
الشباب بالدعم الفني على طول يستلمونه لا
شرح حولوا حول المقدمه
ما يتحول للتدريب الا له مقدم اول ما
يتحول على طول يجي موظف الدعم الفني
يستلمه لين يطلع خمسين فاتوره وهكذا
عندكم معاه واحد من الدعم الفني يعني كل
موظف دعم فني عندك مسؤول عن عدد معين من
العملاء صح يتاكد انهم يتجاوزون 50 مرحله
معينه عشان كذا عندنا مره منخفض
اللي هو نسبه الانسحاب بالضبط نسبه انسحاب
عندنا منخفضه بس وش يسوي يعني مثلا طب
فواتير ووقف
بكل بساطه الين الين لانه اصلا عموله تعمل
فني قائم انه يد انه يطبع 50 فاتوره
محفز جدا انه شو اسمه ان العملاء فعليا
يخلصون
ترى حتى الشباب اللي اللي
خلاص صار الان نشطه مو جاي اسال اسئله
الشباب اللي يردون على الاستفسارات هذولا
على كل رساله يردوا عليها ياخذ عليها نسبه
ياخذ عليها فلوس
انه يكون في عمله وهميين
مره محسوبه
من اكثر من ناحيه مثلا انه لازم العميل
يكون طابخ لازم العميل يكون دافع لازم
العميل يكون نشط
خدمه العملاء
يكلم واحد الخيام من حق الروايه يقول ارسل
لي
ما يقدر لانه
مشترك ولا لا اوكي
مدراء المنتج هم اللي يتابعون انه وش
الناس اللي مثلا البقالات ما يستخدم مخزون
طلعهم على جنب خلنا نكلمهم
فنتواصل معهم ونحاول نحفزهم انهم يستخدمون
النظام بشكل سليم
يراقبون استخدام العملاء بالضبط بحيث انهم
يطورون المنتجات اما بتسهيل خصائص معينه
تجربه يضيف بالضبط
انه يكون عندنا
المنتجات عالميا اصلا هم عددهم قليل
راتبهم مبالغ فيها صراحه وبالسعوديه بشكل
اكبر بكثير والسبب لانه ترى عندنا شركات
تقنيه ترى زي علم وثقه بس ايش المشكله انك
لما تطلع برنامج ابشر غصبا عليه استخدم
ابشر
البرنامج يعني بس انا اقول لك انه مدير
المنتج مو محفز انه لازم يصنع تجربه
خرافيه ومثاليه لانه ترى لو ما سوى كذا
ترى ما راح يستخدم
الخاصيه ما يطلع مدير المنتج جيد الذي
يشتغل في شركه عنده منافسين يشتغل في شركه
ما عندها منافس قد يكون مدير مشروع ممتاز
مره بس لا يسمى مدير منتج صح مدير منتج
يجي واحد يعرف يتفاعل مع السوق يعرف كيف
يحط اشياء تخليك تتفوق على المنافس اما
اذا هي خدمه مثلا مجبورين الناس
يستخدمونها مدير المشروع هذا ليس مدير
منتج وهدفه فقط انه يتاكد من المشروع يطلع
بسرعه صح لكن يسموه مدير
لانه اساسا يعني اتفق معك 100% لكن السوق
يحاول يواكب الموضوع
افضل انا ما ودي نقلب الموضوع عن اداره
المنتجات موضوع معك اللي هو قياس الاداء
كان في نقاش قبل الحلقه بيننا ما دخلنا
تقول تقيس اداء كل موظف في الشركه وش يسوي
بالضبط
بطريقه قياس الاداه بشكل مره مختلف انه
عندنا
وتنزل اوكي هذه الشركه احنا الشركه هذه
اهدافنا نبدا بالاستراتيجيه ثم نبدا
الاهداف ثم هذه الاهداف تنزل الاقسام ثم
الاقسام ينزلونها بشكل ربعي على الموظفين
بالضبط اللي عندك هدف تحته
يعني
الهدف هذا
زين ولكن طبعا الحرب على موضوع الفرع اكثر
ما توقعت يعني من المستثمرين بالضبط عرفت
فتحت عند الشركات التقليديه
اغلب عملائنا كانوا اعمارهم ما بين 28 وال
38 سنه بطبيعه الحال اغلب التجارهم اكثر
بين الاربعين وبين الخمسين او اكثر زين
ولكن لاني انا القنوات التسويقيه اللي انا
جالس استخدم اليوم واتواجد فيها اكثر شيء
حصلوا من الناس هذولا
نوصل للفئه اللي مثلا صعب توصل لعن طريق
سناب شات ولا صعب توصل له عن طريق مثلا
يعني وش الحل خذ لتجارب كثيره تويتر نزلنا
بالشوارع سوينا مثلا موضوع اللي هو
لوحات الشوارع سوينا تفاصيل كثيره نبي
نوصل للفئه اللي نعتقد انه اكثر بكثير من
الفئه الاصعب
الكمبيوتر هذا
قلنا تدري احنا صرنا الكبار وشلون مش ممكن
تسوي اكتشاف اعتماديه على الحركه
الكمبيوتر فقلنا التجربه نستخدم التسويق
يكون مكان بارز وجيد
رئيسي ونستخدمه مسرح لنا اي منتجات جديده
نحط يعني يكون شكل المكان زين فانا
استخدمه
وضبطت الصراحه
الان تقريبا بدينا من السوفت يعني بدانا
تقريبا من شهر
نوعيه من العملاء اللي يدخل على طول ما في
كبار بالسن اوكي ولا يعني يلا يلا يمكن
يستخدم ابشر بس انه عنده نشاط وممتاز
وناجح يبي شيء يبي جهاز
يلمسبين ولا ثلاثه محاسبين عرفت ويبي ناظم
يبي يفهم يعني
هو عملاء خلنا نقول الشركات طبعا ما هي
قاعده بس الشركات تفضل انه تروح تعاين
بضاعتك وتشوفها قبل ما تعقد معك ما تبي
احد يكون بس اونلاين
خلنا نجرب خلينا ندخل على فئه جديده
فنزلنا فيها ورينا اليوم الفرع يعني مغطى
تكاليف يعني اكيد تكاليفه بس ان شاء الله
على نهايه خلنا نقول 6 شهور هذي يعني هات
السنه ان شاء الله نبي نسوي يعني هذا
تقييم مره ثانيه ونتاكد هل هو يستحق الحنا
نكبر ونفتح فروع ولا لا خلاص
الشركات اللي بنيتوها على اساس تقدرون
تحسسون سواء الخدمات اللي تقدمون زي النت
سواء التوزيع سواء الوصول العملة جدة
بتعطيني بس تصور على اشتراكات اللي
سويتوها لنا شيء زي مشروع زي مشروع مستحيل
ينجح لحاله صح لازم يبدي شركات مع مجموعه
من الشركات
يعني في المنطقه بشكل عام
من خلال المنصه حقتنا طبعا الشركات
التقنيه خلال المنصه زيد وسله
وقيود برنامج الشركاء الربط اللي هم يا
برامج محاسبيه يا متاجر الكترون او منصات
تجاره الكترونيه بالضبط حلو وغيرها غير
الربط هذولي من فيه طبعا اس تي سي تقدمون
لكم النت
وناخذ منهم الاجهزه
فالجهاز انا كعمله اشتريته
اليوم لا لازم تطلب النت واعطيك حلو وهذه
تربح منها ناخذ عليها عموله بسيطه مره
يعني لا تذكر حلو فهذه شراكه مع اس تي سي
وايضا قضيه الاجهزه
هذه الهاند هيلد وحتى اجهزه الكاشير تبي
تكون عن طريق اس تي ايضا
صار عندنا خط انتاج خط الانتاج هذا صارت
فيه شوي تقارب فيها فبالتالي صاروا يشترون
خط الانتاج حقنا زين وهم يبيعونه للسوق
بالاضافه الى انه انا عميلي اقول له روح
خذ من اس تي سي خذ الهاردين
يفيدني انه التوصيل
مره ممتازه ما شاء الله زين التوصيل سريع
الخدمه المثاليه
العميل عنده مشكله الاستبدال مره سريع
فاقدم خدمه عظيمه العميليه يعني فانت
اليوم
الاجهزه اللي تضمن انه عندك موزع في
المنطقه اللي هو اس تي سي هو يستفيد من
وفره جهاز يكون عنده مخزون جهاز ممتاز
بتكلفه قليله بالضبط فهو يعطيها لعملاء
رواء وعملاء غير رواء يا سلام اي احد ثاني
هو يوزعه لهم بالضبط وانت تستفيد من في
احد يمسك عنك التوزيع فاذا الحين عملت
بالضبط
فبالتالي هذه فهذه هي تجربه صراحه اللي
انا اعتبرها من التجارب المميزه بالاضافه
الى انه نزلنا برواء فروع
طبعا يعني هو نهايه يعني هي الاشتراكات
قائمه بالنهايه لازم يكون في جدول الاثنين
يعني ودائما اشتراكات القويه اللي تدوم
انه يكون الشريك قوي يقدر يشيل الليله معك
والنقطه الثانيه انه ما راح يكون في تعارض
مصالح كبير على المستوى بعيد
الاستراتيجياتكم ما راح تتعارض فوقتها
تقدر تزيد اعتماديه يعني على الشريك بس ما
قدرت اقنعهم هلا انك انت عندك خط انتاج
بيفيدهم فهم حبوا يفيدونك لا قصه غريبه
بدينا مع
2019 كان متحمسين انا عبد
في
نعرض هواها كما قلت
وجالسين نعرض رواه كذا عندنا كذا صغير
جانا واحد مشاب اس تي سي
وقال لنا
ايش رايكم سمع الفكره وريناه يشتغلوا هذاك
يا شيخ
والله فكره ممتازه ايش رايكم تجون
رحنا وعرضنا وما ضبطت زين
فقالنا هذا تدرون
ان هذه مزبطت
كبرت العلاقه مع الوقت الين صر نسحب
الالاف سحبنا مثلا اول 15
عندها تطبيق فالناس اللي عنده مثلا كاشفان
حق المناديب ومناديب اللي عندهم مناديب
صاروا يشترون عندنا
فصار في نوع من الثقه تخيلوا انه من 2019
من يوم ما قبلنا ابو زياد العمري حتى
الظاهر لغه القطاع غيروا الان
الين الفين 2022 وحنا العلاقه ناس
تقريبا يمكن
[موسيقى]
احنا عندنا صندوق ويمكن ترى يعني
ممكن نستثمر
فقال النوم ممكن يشتغل مع بعض
صار صندوق هذا
ولكن حنا نستاذ اللي فيها اللي فيها توافق
بالضبط اللي فيها يعني علاقه استراتيجيه
الباب
اعتقد في ذاك الوقت عرفت فنزل معنا وقال
لا والله في ترى خلونا نشتغل وفعلا بدينا
وصار استثمار بالاخير يوم صار استثمار
كبرت الشراكه مره صار فيه شراكه على
قطاعات كثير مختلفه عادي
قطاف وصار يعني اشتغلنا على اكثر من قطاع
يعني كل شركه او كل قطاع له علاقه بالبيت
وبي صرنا نشتغل معه بشكل او باخر حلو
للتوضيح هل تقصد اس تي سي ولا اس تي سي
او احد شركات
الاجهزه ولكن مثلا قطاف تبع اس تي سي
يعني كانت
يعني ايه العلاقه اللي بدات في 2019 ثم
بنيناها مع الشريك وصلت بالنهايه الى انه
لا شيء اكبر واستثمر بالنهايه
بشكل مباشر بالشركه الثانيه طيب البنوك
مثلا اشتغلنا مثلا مع البنوك في شركات
ممتازه ما هي بانجح شيء ما زال البنك يشوف
انه لا انت توك صغير يعني وشلون مع انه
ترى تتكلم يعني اكثر من 9 مليار
ريال يمر سنويا تقريبا عمليات من خلال
نظام ولكن البنك لسه يشوف انه شركه صغيره
لا لحظه لكنه في شركات يعني نقول شركات
جيده ان شاء الله انها يعني
خلينا نقول في معاناه لسه يعني في جاب
كبير بين سرعه مثلا
اللي جالسه تسويه مثلا سامه والمدفوعات
السعوديه ويبغون انه يكون عندهم تقنيات
حديثه يبغون يخدمون بشكل جيد وبين رده فعل
البنوك مع التقنيات هذي
ففيه يعني فيش شويه كلها ولا
صح لكن مثلا في بنك يقول لك لا والله اذا
انت مثلا ما انت مشتغل معك الثاني يقول لا
ترى كنت والله توك مثلا لا
يعني يعني في تحديات كبيره صراحه مع
البنوك لكن انا مؤمن انه مع الوقت مثلا
بنك اس تي سي ومع البنوك الرقميه قد انه
يحسن هالامور
يعني هذا اللي نتمناه دخل البنك دخل البنك
يعني هذا اللي حنا يعني يكون في خيارات
كثيره لانه كثره الخيارات ويجون ناس دماء
جديده في السوق اكيد انه راح يبحثون عن
قنوات جديده انهم في السوق اشوف ما شاء
الله السوق غرقان الحين حلول يعني
المدفوعات بس اتوقع وضع النقاط اسوا من
المدفوعات انه
ما في قيمه اغلب الموجودين وسبب ما كل
واحد يقول عن ثلاثه
في حركه اسعار بشكل غير طبيعي كل احد يدعي
يقدم اشياء قد تكون يعني بس في ناس يقدمون
اشياء مو بعدهم اساسا يعني ونسوي قفل
السيل وبعدها اوقف البيعه وبعد ما تشوفون
في صراحه
من اليوم اول شيء
وكيف تشوفون وضعكم المقارنه
فانا احاول اني يعني اني ما اقول ايوه
مكانه بالسوق ولكن
ازعم انه
كثير من المنافسين داخل السوق لان ودو
ياخذ فرصه الفتره الالكترونيه ولكن اعظم
قرار
نوعا المرحله الاولى يعني خلينا نقول انه
كان يعني
[موسيقى]
اعظم قرار استراتيجيه احنا اتخذناه وانه
ترى ما نبي فوتره الكترونيه حنا ما يعني
اعلانات لكن لا ترى هذه القيمه اللي عندنا
ترى هذا الخصائص اللي عندهم اخواني
الوحيده
يعني
ساعدني اني انا اقدم منتجات رهيبه مره زين
حتى ارتب السوق نتكلم على جوده المنتجات
اللي تطلع لانه في فتره الكترونيه
فبالتالي انه اخذ السوق الى بعد مختلف
هذي مال اربع حلقات يمكن
ممتاز
احنا نتكلم هل نتكلم على قضيه انه
قيمتك الوحيده اللي تطبع فاتوره
هذول هم اللي احنا نتكلم عنهم اللي صاروا
كثار وغرقوا السوق وهذه اعلاناتهم حنا
قلنا ترى ما نعلن حنا ميزتنا الكترونيه
نعلن ميزه فقط وازعم انه كان كان صعب
بالبدايه عندك فرصه عندك عندك
شي لطيف وجميل
والحكومه تدعمها التوجه وكان فيه بالضبط
وناس تبحث كثير ولكن وكان قرار يعني كان
قرار صعب ولكنه ازعم انه من قرارات اللي
احنا سويناه لا انا انا اعتقد
نشوف كثير مثلا خاصه البقالات
بقالات ومحلات وغيره وعلى الاقل في اول كم
شهر بعد القرار ساروا يشترون الانظمه هذه
عشان يحطونها في المحل بس صح يعني ما
يستخدمونه فتصور بدا يحسب قيمه البرنامج
الالكترونيه علينا كبيره بس انه غير
مباشره صارت زي الفل بالنسبه لنا صارت
تروح لانها صار يروح مثلا للشركات
اللي مو بافضل شيء مثلا ويعاني ثم يجين
جاهز حلو من ابرز منافسين
فما ركزنا على الفوتره لكنه ركزنا على
قضيه التسويق للقيمه اليوم انت من تشوفينك
في السوق
كانه يعني يقدم
متخصص بالريتين ومستهدف العميل اللي انا
مستهدفه اليوم
مثلا صار عندهم نظام
ولكن ازعم انه رواهي اليوم
ومن كم نسبه تقريبا الاشتراك
اليوم تقدر تقول هامش
تبغاها رياضيا وكيف المستثمرين يحسبونها
شو المناسب
91% تقريبا
قيمه الدعم الفني وقيمه
[موسيقى]
هذا اللي كذا كذا
السيرفرات وتصير شركه ربحيه
فهذا المبدا فيها عشان كذا دائما
المسافرين بس يناظرون تكلفه السيرفرات
والدعم الفني
عدينا 250 سريع
مو مره
يعني خلينا نقول مثلا انهينا مثلا 19
انا هنا مثلا في عشرين موظف بعدين اربعين
اللي هو عشرين عشرين بعدين 21 تقريبا
وصلنا
مئه بعدين نهايه 22 تقريبا عدينا
عدينا المئتين تقريبا او يعني 200 والان
فوق 250 يعني
خلنا نقول نمو بالنسبه للشركات الناشئه
يعتبر نمو ما راح اقول لكم متزن بس اقول
لك
اتوقع مجرد وجود عمليات كبيره على المنصه
برضو تعطيكم فرص انكم تطلعون فلوس
عندنا في المبيعات خلال الاربعه سنوات
الماضيه
ست مئه بالمئه سبعه اضعاف ما شاء الله
سبعه اكس تقريبا خلينا قبل ما ندخل في
الاخر محور اي تقاطعات مع اي مشرعين
عندهم بعض المتطلبات المحلات الانظمه
الكاشير حنا ما الميزه السوق حقنا قطاع
خاص ومن الاشياء اللي انه ما ودنا ندخل في
عشان ما يعني ندخل مع المشرعين فيبطئ
عمليه النمو لانه كل ما زادت التشريعات
كلما بطه بنمو
معهم بالعكس لكنه اللي صاير انه مثلا
يجونا الوزارات
وبعض الهيئات بيحاولون انهم يرضوا
المساعده
فنحاول نشتغل معهم صراحه فالقطاع بشكل عام
يعني من جهتنا احنا كما نتعامل مع الحكومه
زين
ما عندنا ما عندنا تحديات كبيره مع
الحكومه لانه بالعكس يعني اصلا واضح توجه
انه في دعم في دعم كبير للقطاع يمكن
الشركات التقنيه سواء كان من ناحيه فلوس
او تشريعات الصراحه كبيره كمان رايحين
والله التوجه يعني نبغى نخلق قيمه حقيقيه
للتاجر هذا يعني نبغى نكون شريك تقني
حقيقي لتاجر ما ودنا نطلع بس لانه في
تشريعات تخدم القطاع لا نبغى انه فعلا
التاجر يستفيد بس وش ممكن تقدم للتاجر
يعني بخططكم الجايه غير تقدمونا او غير
بنك اس تي سي مثلا الموضوع انا لو احل
التاجر انه كيف انه يتابع كيف انه يتخلص
من قضيه انه داخل الفواتير المشتريات عنده
او انه يجرد تكون طريقه مؤثمه او غير
مكلفه انا اعتقد انه هذه قيمه كبيره مره
مقدمه للتاجر بالاضافه الى الاساسيات
برنامج محاسبه تقريبا ممتاز برنامج اداره
ممتاز اداره مخزون متكامل
والتبعات والملحقاته
فاني انا اقدم يعني تجربه ايضا متكامله من
ناحيه
الاجهزه الممتازه ومن ناحيه ايضا انه مثلا
خدمات البيع تكون جيده والى اخره هذا هو
الهدف الاساسي بالنسبه
يعطيك ابو عساف الله شكرا
لكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في انتاج
المحتوى في التحرير ممرض بيبان في اداره
التصوير ياسر بن غانم في الاضاءه عبد
المجيد عمر الهندسه الصوتيه يوسف ابراهيم
في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى الخراج
الفني مجد الملي ومساعده وسيم معين وفي
الانتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي هذا
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]